proche des vacances une idée insolite
pour vos sorties l'association orcines
de city vous propose de découvrir à
cheval des lieux insolites et aussi
historique sephora namani et camille
lambert se sont rendus dans le parc du
château de groupe ou c'est du côté de
montfort l'amaury à cheval regarder le
château dans lequel on est a été fait
aux 19e et toi que les propriétaires en
fait durant ses voyages
durant leur voyage avaient tendance à
ramener les petits souvenirs donc on
peut traverser différents continents
dans le parc on a plusieurs folie comme
cette pagode au pas au trot ou au galop
plonger dans l'histoire du parc
anglo-chinois du château de grousset
avec baptiste auclair fondateur de horse
in the city
l'association propose des promenades à
cheval dans les parcs des châteaux de
grousset et versailles ou encore dans
les domaines de chevreuse saint cloud et
boulogne
j'ai créé ce concept parce que c'est
vrai que sur paris jean retrouver qui
avait pas beaucoup d'offres sur des
promenades juste pour hu à l'occasion
voilà on est beaucoup de cavaliers à
être montés enfants adolescents et après
être souvent les gens arrêtent
l'équitation et ont par la suite ont
vite 6,6 remettre mais ils ont pas envie
forçant de s'inscrire toutes les
semaines
mon est court mais juste profiter sur
des régions est beau temps de promenade
à l'occasion la balade peut également
être couplée à une visite historique
l'occasion de découvrir pour les
cavaliers débutants et aguerris de
nouveaux décors comme la bibliothèque du
château de groulx s'est construit en
1815 et son théâtre inaugurée en 1957
par la comédie française
un concept sur mesure l'idée c'est quand
même d'aller dans des lieux un peu
atypique d'aller où on n'attend pas trop
le cheval on valorise des promenades
privé et du coup à partir de là en fait
toutes les tous les scénarios sont
possibles
donc c'est vrai qu'on peut on a déjà
scénarisé des promenades avec le demande
en mariage
trois heures d'activités proposées en
français et en anglais dont deux heures
de pratique à cheval et pour récompenser
l'effort
la balade se termine par un pique nique
en compagnie des moniteurs